right a brand new national landmark just
popped up on google maps
it's actually called
brandon falls that's a site where joe
biden fell off a bike and was briefly
pinpointed online before google had to
delete it you can't make people are too
funny online anyway meanwhile more and
more americans are now raising serious
questions about the president's mental
fitness we've only been doing it from
day one today on capitol hill one
congressman is asking
the ever so brilliant buddha judge if
cabinet officials ever discussed the
25th amendment which would remove an
incapacitated president from office take
a look
he falls off bicycles
even at the white house easter
celebration the easter bunny had to
guide him back into his safe place
cue cards that say sit here or end of
speech which he actually states that is
if he stays awake so my question for you
is sir
have you spoken with any other cabinet
members about implementing the 25th
amendment on president biden
first of all i'm glad to have a
president who can ride a bicycle
and
that's
beyond the
insulting nature of that question and
make clear to you that the president
have you spoken to any other cabinet
members about implementing the 25th
amendment on president biden of course
not
here now is former chief of staff mark
meadows along with the lawmaker you just
saw texas congressman troy nels i i did
like the accompanying uh displays that
you brought with your congressman the
reality is and we've shown this often on
this program we spent a lot of time on
this last night a lot of time last week
on it this man is not
cognitively strong enough to be
president it is now more evident than
ever
so even though he's glad we have a
president that can ride a bike maybe we
can get a president that can ride a bike
and not fall off a bike that would be
progress
uh do you think the president's up to
the job congressman
well thank you for having me and back in
uh september of 2019
mayor pete said on cnn i quote if our
presidency is not in good shape then our
country is not in good shape and it just
wasn't mayor pete it was the entire left
and the dishonest media that railed on
donald trump for four years donald trump
wasn't in office for a month and they
started saying that he was uns unfit to
serve and they questioned his mental
health and his cognitive skills and it's
interesting
we've have 18 months of joe biden and
you so you we saw it on on the
television where he's shaking hands with
casper and imaginary people
i mean you had the easter bunny gaffe
and he he falls asleep in all these
meetings so no i thought it was a very
fair question because he is the leader
of the free world
he's the leader of the free world and
our adversaries are taking advantage of
this weakness and i thought it was a
very fair question to ask mayor pete
about the 25th you know donald trump
took a cognitive test mark meadows he
aced it 30 out of 30. why can't joe
biden take one
well obviously the american the american
people are real concerned uh but it's
not just with his mental health or his
ability uh as the congressman was
pointing out i think it's really about
the policies that are coming out of this
and who's in control sean uh you know
when you start to look at at his poll
numbers historic lows in three new polls
fox news poll cnn reuters all three of
them joe biden has uh you know historic
clothes now for him and everybody's
looking for an explanation so if it is
not
you know his ability his cognitive
ability then what is it it must have to
be deliberate and they must be looking
at inflicting pain as you covered
earlier
i would argue that any liberal that
replaced him would do the same thing but
more specifically let's play the tape i
play it often i could play hours of joe
biden's gaffes listen
the political coverage
[Applause]
[Music]
that
look
um
some of the political
players
and some of the
[Music]
let me ask you a rhetorical question
no anyway
mark meadows is that man up to the job
of president
no obviously when you start to look at
the ability to respond in rapid pace uh
you know the the kind of decisions that
come to the oval office on a regular
basis president trump would go out and
do what we call chopper talk he would
have rapid fire questions from every
single news media out there and for an
hour and handle them uh with you know
with unbelievable prowess so that's what
we need in the oval office
anyway thank you mark meadows
congressman great job today uh you can
bring
any displays anytime you want
i thought it was well pointed out today
good job and we need to have that
conversation about the 25th amendment
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else